S
EARLIEEFULLY INPUT HERE TODAY.
Y APPRECIATEATTO
INIEWEE  PROVIDE
INVESTIGATION AND CAREFULLY
ALLTHE LAW.
NTALGOING TO B GNG WRITING.
I HAVE 2O BE THE
SENTENCINGRDER.
WHY AMT NGHASIZET E APPROPATE Y.
IT'S APPLYING THE RULE O
THE FAOF AN INDIVIDUAL AND
AND THAT IS WH TO
TRYING TO BE PROFOUND N
CORDI PREF TS THAT IERWHAT THE .
BUT AT THE SAME TIMEE THE DEEP I
E THE PAINOT ONLY O SD I OWD HEL
OF THOSE COURT B
THE FL W AIS COMTY HASN PAINFU
CO WIZE THE PAIN OF THFL
I AM NOT
NOT THOTASIN SENTENCE AL
C OPINIO NASING IT ON AN
TED Y SS.
T  JOB OF URT JUTHLAC VIDUAL.
AND,R. CHAUVINAS
COSED ON THE VERDICT
OF THE JURY FINDING TY
OF UNINTENTIONAL SECGREE
CDE
REN 1, IT IS THE JUDGMENT OF
THE COURT THAT YOU NOW STAND
T OFFENSE.
PURSUANT TA STATUTE
SECTION 6090 TWO A WILL REMAIN
AS THEY LE OFFENSEUN
AND THNTENCENTE U TO THE STODY
ODF 270 MONTHSTH 270S  F 150
MONTHS.
ISS BASED R ABUSE OF A
F TRUSD AUTH
AND SO PARTICULAR CRSHOWN TO GE.
YOU ARE GRTED CREDIT FOR 199
DAYS ALREADY
PAE MAORY SURCHARGE
YO FROM
POSSESSINGUNORE REMAINDEOUPRE A
REGISTER AS A PREDY UIU WILL
RECEIVE R  THE ATTACHEUMEXAITHE
>>R F THIS NDS
CURRENTLY HOLDHIHICHEVER CUSTODI
>>THDJNG FROM THO,OU
IN HAS BSENTEND 2 AND A HALF Y
YO>> JUSTICEPERFECT. IS A SENTES
SENTENCE.HE JUDGE SHOULD'V
MINNESOTA GUIDELINES SAY YOU C
1S S E AGGRAVATORE D
KNE G 15 YEA FORR CLOS>> VERY DI
S OFG
ON.
VERY DISAPPOINTING LEVEL
OFE OF THOSEHA MAN, D'VE BEETHD
R DID IS THA Y.
CAN'T DO THIS TYPE
BACHOME.
JENNIFER?
YEA
THE SENTENCE ISN'T 1ARS.ENCE I
THE DGN'T CONSIDERTHAT WHEN TEN.
E S DOS LIGHT, LIKE YOL DO.
COMMISSIONE>> I THOUGHT
ERE IN BETWEEND Y WHAT ID OF THT
LD W BEING.
IT. T JUDGE'S DECISION.
OF TY CLEA  A NEW.AR A 22 , IF S
TH CAN JUSFYIT IN ANMANNERSHAPE
FORM, IN MINN. DBUAGAIHAE S
THE DECISION, YOU LIVE  IEMO EXI
IS THAT >>
P INO CTMENT ELAR EXACT
PENDING AGAINST REK CHAUVIN.YD R
R R-OLD
14-YEAR-OLD BEUS'S A I IT THEYA
SEPARATE INCIDENT, MEANI
N BACK.
GOING TO SAY YOU HAVEA  OHE
MENT OF JUSTICLOATTHIS.
THE FEDS CAN CIN AND DEYDO MUSE
THIS IS NOT >> LIVCT OUTSIDE OFH
WHAT WE JUST HEARD,  A AORUV
GEYDRE
THERE.
JENNIFER RODGERS, LAST WORD
YOU.
THE IMPACT OF  WE
TODAS SAYING
THAT WD FROMLONISEYING THAT WE V
REGARDLESS OF THE SENTENCE FOR
DEREK CHAUVIN, THEY HAVE THE
LIFEENTENC YEAH.THERE'S NE